so if you said silicone is what Kim
Kardashian and Silicon Valley have in
common
creative but that's not where I'm going
with this here's why because there's a
difference between silicon which is a
14th element on the periodic table
versus silicone which is a synthetic
substance that people use for many
different things that you can figure out
but this isn't that video port let me
tell you why it's a waste of time for
you to constantly compare your business
to Silicon Valley in Kim Kardashian you
are guaranteed to be disappointed 100
percent to be disappointed
here's why there's celebrities there on
TV magazines love writing about it MSNBC
News MSN Money all these channels love
talking about companies and silicone
they're going public they're amazing
there's this data and so all these
younger entrepreneurs coming up - oh my
gosh I want to be like those guys I want
to start a company technology company
out of Silicon Valley but what they
don't realize the following only 4% of
fortune 500 companies are based out of
Silicon Valley only five and a half six
percent of Forbes 400 richest people are
based out of Silicon Valley only that
much now watch this yeah I want you to
keep it so much when we're saying only
five only six percent stay here with me
why should I not want to be like Silicon
Valley or Kim Kardashian here's why
number one it's simply reality TV Kim
Kardashian's life is not real it's
reality TV to get millions of people to
watch not for you to say I want to be
Kim Kardashian one day think it's not
real its fake Silicon Valley it's fake
it's a small little bubble that they
have it's not real business the way they
run their businesses is not the way you
run 99.9% of businesses around the world
around the country number two math never
make sense
how'd it can become famous it's the
question of body ask how did this
company pay 20 million dollars to this
business in this business only does 400
million dollars a year revenues why did
Facebook pay so much money to Instagram
Instagram wasn't even making money what
happened there the math doesn't make
sense
so you running a business real
legitimate business that you can show
math it's different than Silicon Valley
number three you
be disappointed if you compare 100% of
time well when I look at Tim's life and
I look at these people in Silicon Valley
their businesses are so amazing I must
be a terrible CEO or an entrepreneur or
this or that you're not listen let me
tell it's you in a complete different
way I'm here to tell you I want to I
want to tell you this the guy that's
running the business doing 17 million
dollars a year with his or her business
that she grew from zero to 17 million
years she may be as good of a CEO as any
of those CEOs in Silicon Valley yes
absolutely why because in Silicon Valley
one can go raise money and get ten
million around 150 round to 200 round
three and they bring the right people on
they had one great idea blows up and
then they say this guy's the greatest
year of all time but the person who's 70
million dollars you may be a better CEO
you can't compare yourself on what
Silicon Valley does next they live on an
island of their own there's a complete
different Island they go in a complete
different community you guys grow up in
a different school college environment
the restaurants the place during a
completed for an environment then you
are maybe at a Toledo or maybe out of
dilute or maybe out of you know Austin
or Jacksonville or some of these cities
that you may be a part of completely
different life number to number 5 few
duplicatable habit you know what's a
duplicate of a habit what Sam Walton did
is duplicatable what Jeff Bezos did is
duplicatable habit what people take
regular businesses and they build it
into conglomerates those are
duplicatable habits that you could do
here's why let me remind you of this 60%
listen Warren exciting 60 percent of
Fortune 500 companies from 1970 are no
longer around today do you know what
that means here's 500 companies 300 of
them gone only 200 of them are around
from 1970 what does that mean to you huh
that means Silicon Valley maybe nothing
40 years from now and no one even talks
about it except for textbooks in
universities to say mistakes that were
made or things they did right now I'm
not telling they don't do a lot of
things I lose it I use a lot of their
companies and I invest into them but to
use your business on
how they do it don't forget that this
can happen if you go to a place that
everybody goes to and it's already
predictable you're leaving all the other
opportunities that no one is even paying
attention to now having said that let me
tell you duplicatable way that you could
do something to build your business
something that is completely different
than this reality TV that they live in
very simple typically here stuff
somebody becomes an entrepreneur they
learn how to sell they learn how to
create because they shadow somebody so I
work under someone elementary sketches
how he said this is great I can do this
as well here time makes phone calls I
can do this as well do did you see what
exactly do that as well no no try to
light it today shadow someone they see
somebody design something create
something they build this desk they
build this car they build an engine they
go man I shadow them I see this is kind
of cool I can do this or they broker a
product they sell real estate they sell
insurance they sell them as their broker
and somebody else's product that they
didn't create themselves but they learn
how to broker that product they do this
for a while then you save money you save
10 grand 20 grand 50 grand 100 round 200
300 of your own money in your pocket
because you did this for a couple years
then you save your money
then you shall prove that you know what
you're doing in an industry you become
an expert you and a group of people
decide to start a business and you own a
piece of the company you want to see
that I saw the business together then
you raise money then you build your
business then you had to sell it up or
you keep growing your company this my
friends is duplicatable this is reality
TV so enclosing if you compare your
personal life to our friend Kim
Kardashian or if you run your business
and you compare you to all the people in
Silicon Valley you are bound to be
disappointed and discouraged with
yourself focus on your game focus on the
fundamentals focus on what works focus
on growing your base your business your
company your life your personal life see
what you can do to make that better and
believe me a big victory could be around
the corner for you as well if you do it
right you got any questions comments
thoughts comment on the bottom if you
have any friends in Silicon Valley be
sure to share this video with them
because I'm sure they're going to love
this video and if you haven't subscribed
to this channel stop here join a
notification squad by clicking on that
alert button as well
come on
[Music]